Brian Grazer is the Academy
award-winning producer behind hit movies
like Beautiful Mind and Apollo 13 and
the emmy-winning TV series 24 and
Arrested Development and Empire razor
now has a new series it's called genius
on National Geographic explorers a
private life and discoveries of Albert
Einstein Geoffrey Rush plays a brilliant
scientist later in his life Betty
move in with me you have a wife I'm
quite rational actually Onaga me is not
naturally it is a construct of religious
authority the foolish faith and
authority my dear Betty is the first
enemy of truth truth being that rules
don't apply to you I love Mozart and
Bach I love this results and the Baltic
Sea if I can't I love you I'd answer for
a man who is an expert on the universe
you don't know the first thing about
people do you no he doesn't
please welcome Brian Grazer to studio 57
your partner in crime
Ron Howard said it's not just an
academic experience we wanted people to
know the whole dude so you got my
attention when it opens with him
blinking his assistant up against the
board with his pants literally at his
ankles Brian exactly what we want to
humanize so this it's got very modern
thematics yeah it's likes romance
breakthroughs the way we see an
experience our universe uh-huh but the
scene that preceded it that you're
referring to is he is against the black
border has Betty against the black board
he's sexing her
that's his secretary yes and as they
finish he decides very gentlemanly to
wipe and then of course reinstate his
equation yes I'm still recovering from
the use of the word boinking on CBS this
morning oh well that's better than the
other word but I one thing I really like
about this is is this is it's really
rare when you see a TV show make a
scientist or a mathematician the hero it
well it is rare
we were very fortunate we did a
beautiful mind and and that was a sort
of a version of that and it's difficult
to make science cinematic but Ron Howard
is quite brilliant at this he did that
very well in a beautiful mind and also
in Apollo 13 and science has become and
genius has become very sexy it's a it's
replaced reality television I mean it
people all want to know how things are
done and genius is a sexy way of
accomplishing that it does give the
fuller picture to of Einstein and as the
New York Times described it we see in
him as an errant lover a draft dodger an
adulterer a clueless rebel an arrogant
self-centered dreamer and a stubborn
curious soul it challenges our
perceptions of us all we know it's a
crazy air Brian yeah crazy air that's
all we know crazy hair and then genius
and math yeah looking at a very
attractive woman
I mean he was a bad boy I mean he was a
bad boy in every way he's kind of a
artist bad boy that had to flee where he
was because of Nazi Germany and what was
going on there and come to America but
he was a superstar like he was very
famous you see him as the original
disrupter yeah well I do see him as the
original disrupter but so do many of the
disruptors like Bill Gates or Steve Jobs
or Jeff Bezos or any of them see Albert
Einstein as the progenitor of that I
mean he was the first person to really
challenge anything that was kind of
solid fact which would be Newtonian
physics and the way we see and
experience the world and he prevailed in
that your friend and business partner
Ron Howard is the executive producer
directs the first episode you've done so
much together what is that what is the
secret of that relationship
communicating through telepathy well we
we we we always intersect on the same
kind of value system and taste yeah so
and this is one of the things that we
really really wanted to do and Ron does
find a way to make things very cinematic
and he brought that to television yeah
it's a 10 part series and the prediction
is that people will want a binge watch
for the first time a science project on
Albert
sign you don't see that in the same
sentence binge watch never I know you
guys had read that very excited but it's
super juicy you have to check it out
Brian Grazer thank you so much you see
genius premieres Tuesday on National
Geographic and you can hear more of CBS
this morning on our podcast find
extended interviews and podcast
originals on iTunes and Apple's podcast
at